hi guys scifi recapped here
before we start warning
spoilers ahead today i'm gonna explain a
2010 action movie called the karate kid
the movie begins with an american
teenager named dre parker who currently
lives with his widowed mother sherry in
order to find a better life they decide
to move from detroit to china despite
not knowing the country's language and
culture at all
dre tries to learn mandarin on the plane
but it seems like he is struggling
sherry is surprised when she learns that
chyna is not that old as pictured in the
magazine
upon arrival at the apartment dre seems
hopeless when he finds out that
spongebob is also dubbed in chinese and
he doesn't understand the language at
all
sherry immediately goes to the bathroom
and takes a bath but however the hot
water is broken
dre is ordered by his mom to find the
maintenance man mr han
he tries to speak english to the local
people but no one seems to understand
what he is saying
long story short he finds mr han and
asks him to go to his room to fix the
water but he ignores him while
attempting to capture a fly with his
chopsticks but later hits it with a fly
swatter afterward he explores the place
and finally meets a teenager who also
speaks english named harry and befriends
him
after badly losing to an old man in
table tennis dre spots a young violinist
maying tries to talk to her
it seems that the girl also likes dre
especially with his unique hair
however they are later confronted by
chang who is unhappy when he sees dre is
flirting with meiyang
the american boy tries to intervene and
challenges chang but gets beaten up
badly by him as the chinese boy is way
too strong for him
the next day dre attempts to cover his
bruises with his mom's makeup he attends
the local school where he finds out that
he is in the same school with mei ying
chang and his gang
at the cafeteria chang shows up and
deliberately slams dre's food tray
he can't do anything as the teacher
comes and separates them
at the same time maying seems worried
about dre
that afternoon mr han finally comes to
the apartment where he spots dre is
practicing kung fu from the television
mr han calls dre to teach him how to
operate the hot water but gets ignored
thus he tosses a toothpaste cap towards
dre which accurately hits him and makes
him surprised
not long after sherry returns home and
is very annoyed with his son's
undisciplined behavior while mr han
eavesdrops on their conversation
back at school dre comes across a room
where he finds maying practicing violin
for the upcoming audition
she claims that joining the academy is
very important for her and her family
thus she has to give her best he leaves
the room and suddenly is confronted by
chang and his gang who warn him to keep
distance from maying while bullying him
after school dre and his mom pay a visit
to forbidden city and they come across
an enormous group of teenagers
practicing kung fu
he explores the place but accidentally
arrives at a room where he learns that
chang is actually a kung fu expert he
gets upset and immediately asks his mom
to leave
sherry becomes worried asking dre about
what actually happened
he reveals that he hates the country and
blames his mom's decision for moving to
china the following day just after a
school trip to the forbidden city dre
feels like this is the perfect time for
revenge he quietly follows chang and his
gang takes a bucket of dirty water and
throws it over the boys
this action makes the boys furious who
immediately chase him around the city
after a long and exhausting pursuit dre
eventually arrives at backstreet alley
and hits a dead end
he tries to escape but chang manages to
pull him to the ground
the enraged boys then corner him and
start punching him ruthlessly
when chang is about to launch his final
blow suddenly mr han shows up and grabs
his wrist the maintenance man tells them
to go home but the kakichang tries to
kick him instead which is blocked by mr
han
turns out that mr han is a kung fu
master he manages to dodge the boys
strikes smoothly and knock them out
without even launching a single
offensive move on them causing them to
beat each other up
chang and the gang eventually give up
and flee from the place
mr han brings dre home and treats his
wounds with an ancient chinese healing
method fire cupping dre begs mr han to
teach him kung fu for self-defense but
it seems like mr han isn't interested in
teaching anybody at the moment however
he later accompanies dre to visit the
fighting dragon academy to make peace
with chang and his teacher lee
lee is a ruthless and cruel teacher who
always teaches his students to show no
mercy towards their opponent he refuses
the peace offer and challenges either
dre or mr han fights against chang but
they walk away as they have no intention
to make the situation worse
mr han sees a kung fu competition poster
and challenges him to prove who is the
best there which is then accepted by
master lee
since he doesn't understand mandarin at
all dre is shocked when informed by mr
han that he has to fight all of them at
the tournament mr han reveals that what
master lee taught was not kung fu since
he only taught cruelty to his students
thus he promises dre that he will teach
him the real kung fu
dre is very excited and immediately
heads over to mr han's place upon
arrival he comes across a broken car
inside the house
he meets mr han and the training begins
however dre is upset when he learns that
that training set is not what he
expected he is told to pick up his
jacket hang it up and then take it down
repeatedly
dre doesn't realize that the day one
training set has taught him how to be
more disciplined
day by day has passed but the take it
down hang it up training set still
continues he keeps practicing even the
weather can't stop him suddenly sherry
pays a visit and invites dre and mr han
to go with her to the shishi festival
upon arrival at the festival dre comes
across a building where he meets meijing
who later asks him to watch a show with
her
there he invites maeyang to come to the
upcoming kung fu tournament to support
him and he will also go to her audition
meanwhile mr han reveals to sherry that
she audrey the nickname that he gave to
her son is his very first kung fu
student
at some point dre is fed up with the
same boring training set and rudely
states that he wants to quit
he also blames mr han saying that he
doesn't understand kung fu at all
disappointed with the statement mr han
stands up and shows dre the real purpose
of that repetitive training set which is
to develop muscle memory
at the same time dre is also surprised
when he somehow manages to dodge
upcoming attacks from mr han
the teacher then says that kung fu lives
in every aspect of life including
putting on and taking off the jacket
since then dre has put a lot of respect
towards mr han
the next day mr han takes stray to a
temple in wudong mountain the place
where mr han used to learn kung fu
there dre witnesses exceptional kung fu
abilities and techniques he is
fascinated when he sees a woman who is
able to control a snake who copies her
head movement
at the end of the journey they arrive at
dragon well where mr han orders dre to
taste the water
after that mr haunt escalates the
training to the next level this time
focusing on dre's concentration body
fitness and flexibility after numerous
sets of exhausting training it is seen
that dre has developed a better body
form and the teacher gives him a day off
in his spare time dre takes maying with
him to explore the city they have a lot
of fun and meijing also shows off her
dancing skill to the boy who is amazed
with her ability
suddenly maying receives a call
informing her that the audition is
rescheduled to today
she is then picked up with her father
and is nearly late for the audition
dre silently follows them to the
auditorium and witnesses the girl's
performance
however meiying's parents don't really
like dre and forbid their daughter from
seeing him again
the heartbroken dre then comes to mr
han's house finding his teacher is in a
drunk state and destroying the broken
car
turns out that day is the day when he
lost his wife and son in a car accident
after the pair had an argument
since then mr han claims that he still
cannot forgive himself to help his
teacher overcome his past trauma dre
pulls him out of the car and asks him to
continue the training
dre becomes motivated to train harder so
that he can win the competition and
impress his teacher
after passing several weeks of drilling
mr han concludes that dre is ready for
the competition and brings him to the
competition venue he also presents him a
bruce lee's fighting suit to increase
his morale
later that night dray bravely pays a
visit to meiyeng's house where he
apologizes to her father in mandarin
the father appreciates the effort and
accepts the apology
he also promises that mein will come to
the tournament to support him
finally the d-day of the tournament has
come
the venue is full of spectators and it
seems like the fighters participating in
the tournament are very strong
dre attends his very first official
battle however he doesn't understand the
rule and walks out of the circle mat
causing him to lose a point in the next
round he finally gains his confidence
and eventually manages to eliminate his
first opponent
meanwhile the boys from fighting dragon
academy also proceed to the next phase
of the tournament
chang defeats the blue suited boy easily
and becomes the first finalist to reach
the grand final on the other side dre is
able to win the next matches until he
reaches the semi-final and faces one of
the strong boys from the academy liang
before the match master lee orders him
to break his leg
he reluctantly obeys the order even
though it means that he will be
disqualified from the semi-final as
planned liang plays dirty in the fight
and deliberately strikes his punches on
dre's leg repeatedly the american boy is
badly hurt and the doctor states that it
is impossible for dre to continue
fighting despite advancing to the grand
final meanwhile chang is ready to claim
the trophy if dre is unable to return in
several minutes
dre begs mr han treats him with a fire
cupping method as he believes that he
has a big chance to win the tournament
he initially refuses because he doesn't
want to watch dray getting hurt again
but dre somehow manages to convince him
a few moments later dre returns to the
ring and the grand final begins
dre loses the first round after being
kicked out from the arena by chang
fortunately he comes back and regains
his position into a 2-1 lead as expected
chang plays dirty and purposely aims
dre's weak leg
he launches a powerful jump kick towards
the injured leg causing dre to scream in
agony and cheng claims a point for
winning the round in the deciding round
dre insists to keep fighting despite
standing with one leg
he remembers the woman who controlled
the snake on the mountain and copies her
technique
chang underestimates him and charges
towards him allowing dre to strike an
overhead kick to his face
chang is unable to get up and dre
officially becomes the champion of the
tournament with respect chang hands over
the trophy to dre while the other
fighting dragon students bowed down to
mr han
subscribe to watch more videos like this
turn on notifications and leave a like
to help the channel out thank you for
watching